let's go next to let's go next to Tim
from the 631 it's been a few months
since I heard from argumentative Tim as
we have him in our call system what's
going on - oh that's my nickname hon
David yeah oh good to hear from you I've
been following you for quite some time I
saw a lot of people quite some time and
I wanted to get your take on you know
the current status of the rollout of
opening businesses and what your take is
on the Dallas woman that recently got
arrested and sent to jail for opening
her business while there at the same
time letting criminals out on the street
I think it's very counterproductive I
don't know anything about that story in
Dallas I just have not seen it or read
about it but I'll check it out I mean
here's my dear Tim my sense is that
there are states that have numbers that
justify safe socially distancing
reopening of some elements of the
economy we're starting to see the
numbers improve in a bunch of different
states and I want the economy reopened
as quickly as is safely possible so
that's fantastic on the other hand I'm
also seeing some states where the cases
are exploding Texas is an example where
10 days ago they had about four to six
hundred new cases today now Texas has
eight to twelve hundred new cases a day
so I have no special insight I'm just
looking at the data and listening to
health experts it seems there are states
that aren't yet ready well a lot of
those numbers when it comes to more
people getting it and more people being
asymptomatic is actually good news if
you have a higher mortality rate we've
actually broken the curve especially in
places where I'm from New York I have
family out there it seems to be kind of
breaking the fever at the word it's not
as bad as it once was well I think
what's important to look at though is a
lot of these states have very low
testing rates so let me I'll give you
one example and see if this resonates
with you in Massachusetts we test at
about three and a half times the rate of
text
and the we used to always have more new
cases in Massachusetts than in Texas
that's reversed and for a couple of days
in the last week Texas had more new
cases than Massachusetts despite only
testing at about 30 percent of the level
of Massachusetts so that's one thing I
would certainly look at the other is the
deaths are not based on testing so when
you look at the actual deaths those are
also spiking in Texas so I think you
know your point is well-taken but when
you see death spiking as well that's not
about testing rates what we're seeing
right now I think is a very big rise in
authoritarianism so the Dallas woman I
described
she was actually told on video and this
is all over Fox this is one of the
biggest news stories in the United
States I'm not sure how you haven't seen
it but when it comes to the judge he was
a leftist judge that tweeted with her
you will apologize and Bend to me unless
I will take you to jail if you don't and
she didn't which I'm happy for her but
that's the type of power grabbing we're
seeing in the United States right now
and it's absolutely unacceptable and it
goes against people's rights I would
sure your great you would agree as a
liberal you know either classical
liberal otherwise it's going against
their constitutional rights and a huge
scale what what's wait hold on
what goes against whose constitutional
right and which right being able to feed
their families people being able to feed
their families based off of fear that
mass backed by credible numbers has not
backed by facts we're taking stuff on
the TDC where one minute they're saying
that uh who by the way is thirty percent
funded by China wait a second okay to
where that it's not okay to wear a mask
Tim you know where I'm at by piece here
Tim we gotta go I want to really
understand what you're saying
so which constitutional right is
violated by a stay at home public health
of guideline illegal seizure on the
twenty of them you gotta stop them with
who what what search and seizure happens
when people are told you should
they home and wear a mask in public
what's the search and seizure okay
someone's someone's at a park they get
arrested by the police like the woman in
Idaho then they search your vehicle is
that illegal
you're all over the place to him we're
not talking about how my question was
and seizure so so they search your car
after in their property and take her kid
that wasn't my question
what about a stay at home order isn't it
is an anti constitutional illegal search
and seizure okay so when you don't stay
at home and go to a place like a public
park where your tax dollars pay for and
then they arrest you there because
you're not apparently it's the park oh
hold on is the park oh because Park
Rangers have authority right is the park
open or closed because if it's closed
you're trespassing right not federally
all right Tim all right my friend Tim's
all over the place he we can't stay at
first it was about a woman in Texas then
it's about Constitution then it's about
search and seizure then it's about it's
a closed Idaho Park but then he says
it's it's not federal but you said it
was Idaho Tim's all over the place
one of our sponsors today is VIN Chara
watches giving you 15% off your entire
order when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch don't pay thousands of
dollars for a high-quality watch that
looks great because you don't have to
all of inch arrows watches are made with
high end materials masterfully built and
they look like something you'd spend a
ton of money on but ever even chera
watch ranges from about a hundred and
fifty to three hundred bucks I went over
to their website and picked out the
bellwether and silver and white really
nice elegant look and a lot of people
ask me where's the watch from really
really great look totally different they
also sent me the altitude in matte black
and red a much more rugged view of what
a watch can look like really liked it as
well as well as the athletic strap it's
a new year it's a new decade it's time
to re-establish your style add something
new to your look and a high-quality
watch is the perfect way to do that you
can get 15% off inch arrows entire
collection when you go to David
mancom /watch